Zootopia a gleaming city where animals
of all breeds predator and prey alike
live together in peace and harmony yeah
well we're loud I'm expected to
apologize for it
CPD's first rabbit officer Judy Hopps
ready to make the world a better place
bad news in this city gripped by fear
what can you tell us about the animals
that went savage are we safe this is
Priority One
ops parking duty sir I'm not just some
token bunny you strike out you is I deal
well I'm here to ask you some questions
back then they should have gotten a real
cop to solve it you are under arrest for
what
hurting your feelings you are a key
witness no he is hey I need you to run a
plate all right I know a guy you need
something done he's on it they're all
slots
we are in a really big hurry I am on its
break I have 36 hours that we can only
solve it together it's not about how bad
you want something it's about what you
are capable I am a real cop never let
them see that they get to you bunny is
so emotional maybe love but deep down
we're still anima quit it you're gonna
start a whole you are naked for sure
we're naturalist Club way down
life's a little bit messy
Janice
we all make mistakes no matter what type
of animal you are change starts with you
we gotta go this guy's the most feared
crime boss mr. bean
that mr. pig's knocking stop talking did
we say no maybe various VX Novell and
how it is canadaís I'm flares flares
splits Ned on fish company listed a soon